if you're in a job you're thinking about
leaving it and you've experienced a pay
rise and your happiness hasn't increased
in proportion of the pay rise leave or
self-medication when the existential
pain starts to bear so much on your
shoulders that you like I'm gonna just
blast myself on Friday to Sunday I'm
just going to ingest things yeah yeah in
desperate hope that it's gonna make this
people should be allowed to enjoy
themselves on a weekend but if that
enjoyment is medication or if that
enjoyment on a weekend is if it's done
in an effort to be like an anesthetic
for what's going on in a week people
think they starch up like brush out
schools from uni and I like arts a bit
crap but it'll probably get better and
then like 20 years later it's not got
better the person who loves a
nine-to-five job is the person who is
alright with their [ __ ] things about the
nine-to-five job the person who's good
as it entrepreneur as a person alright
with the fact that like next month you
might make no money might may another
money and that you know next month has
six months you might be out of business
can you deal with potentially going for
two months or three months without
earning any money
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Johnny and Yousef from propane
fitness comm business principles 102 102
did so good did so good on the last one
don't go I'm gonna do it again do not
that one was one of our most popular new
episodes that we've released in a while
went down super super well and this
episode is brought to you by so right if
you haven't seen one of these before Joe
Rogan and David Goggins went on about it
for ages on their podcast together and
it shut their website down so there's a
business principle for you make sure you
got enough server space that if Joe
Rogan and David Goggin start talking
about your product doesn't break be
ready be ready
so it is a source manipulation tool if
you sit down a desk all day we are
talking business principles if you talk
sit down at a desk all day you will have
a tight so us I'm right in saying it's
the only muscle which actually connects
the trunk to the spine is that right or
one of the primary muscles that has it
so it gets tight when you sit down that
helps to relieve it we've all got one
and we've been using it pretty regularly
just helped when you've been sat
cranking out a big long day in the
office and to relieve things so all that
you need to do leave us a review on
iTunes or whatever ever you are
listening and I'll pick some up wind
sorry it's not the only muscle that
excellent trunk to the spine it's the
only muscle that crosses the pelvis the
kinetic oh yeah thank you very much
there we go
well so a little bit I think that's
interesting they can eat so if I
believed in you if I cook you you are
see using the so right then it would be
tender lovely it's not load-bearing
ecology why so tender interesting so
business principles one or two yeah we
talked about a lot last time we talked
about hours of Genesis stories for
business about how we got started about
how useless university degree is when it
comes to ring a business so one of the
main questions that we get asked a lot
is when someone should make the decision
but whether or not to leave their
current employment and take the big leap
into being self-employed yeah pulling
that pin you started to talk about your
decision when you're selling a couch
that are no longer how I think I've made
the decision by then yeah um so it is
it's yeah it's like jumping out and
playing and hoping that the parachute
cord would hmm people make the decision
often either way to prematurely like Oh
me I'm gonna start like a new tea
company is gonna be sick new clients but
like I'm working I'm just gonna quit my
job like I'm currently working as like a
management consultant but anyway like I
I know that like I just need like two
days get my drop ship in so is gonna
said that's like going you are eight
months away from launch and you have two
weeks of well I see no just wait until
you your revenue profits start to like
eclipse your salary and then it's like
oh okay
hmm so I think one of the cool
interesting little thought experiments
that we've done over the last couple of
years which is a good strategy to do
with other people as well if you hear
someone complaining about the job or
complaining about the boss or whatever
it might be this is a good strategy to
use on them and we promise that we're
gonna do it before the last one so what
we're gonna do is we're going to take a
salary now at home you can take your own
salary and deduct as it's appropriate
but we'll have to Johnny I'm gonna
pretend that you are personally normal
some normal job let's say that you're
taking on paper use 20,000 pounds okay
gross okay let's say let's say let's say
20 grand
that's about 1,200 quid a month I think
event mister received I believe okay so
if it's 20 grand gross do you do not
believe me it is 20 grand net trying on
gross
20 grand gross and that
like a maybe just the lowest starting
salary for a graduate scheme something
like that many 1:22 thing it's pretty
much a starting salary cool so you've
got 20 grand and I am going to you are
the normal Graduate scheme but let's
imagine that you're someone who's a
little bit unhappy with the job thinking
about maybe starting up their own thing
I'm going to offer you some concessions
at work so this was me yeah I'm gonna
offer you some concessions okay and I
want you to tell me how much of your
wage you're going to give me back for
the things that I'm offering that you
can have okay oh I doing this as me as
you as you in the role that you were at
the job that you are at the time of your
life so you are allowed to wear your own
clothes whenever you want so you don't
need to go to work in office dress how
we're not gonna get me back per month or
per year Pia take it off for 20 so yeah
I have trouble fitting in the suits
that's a hundred quid across the whole
year of course the whole yeah this is
monthly no so I grind it up oh no no I
can't think like that
pretty monthly twelve hundred pounds a
year 100 pounds a month but then grosser
than that yeah just like I get 20 quid a
month an intake change for good for that
time reckon I have to go somewhere and
do stuff dressing a certain way at a
certain time okay
so you're saying I have to do all that
but go pajamas jogging bottoms and [ __ ]
yeah how much you getting a hundred quid
so I'm very good about 1100 left okay
now you can choose your own start time
and you can choose if you want to have
weekends off you can basically ultimate
flexi time okay could get up at 6 p.m.
at night and do the shift so I 13 35
hours a week but as I please yes can't
believe you get me a hundred quid back
per month just like I've got it now
sorry because I've boxed myself into a
situation yet yeah because soon I'll
just have nothing we can renege on the
quite hot Rene and he's given as it he's
already gonna hot [ __ ] how much you how
much to acquit another two hundred yeah
for you to be able to flex around well
because now hold on is location flexed
just lover to go the place still go to
go to work hundred hundred oh I should
have done fifty for the clothes I'm not
too late sorry
so you're a ground just don't fit me
you're at a grunge months now yeah okay
and I'm naked essentially coming in
whenever I want yeah okay pretty good
situation do you mean you say pretty
good situation or a grand a month
yeah not bad yeah now you don't have to
interact with anyone at work that you
don't want to
no thank you it's fine said is that I'm
gonna be difficult
does that mean that like a boss comes up
to me goes you've got to do this let's
go and they just get wouldn't know but
it would be black Mara blocking moon
style it would be submit through someone
that you actually liked everyone that
you work doesn't affect my work flow
everyone that you worked with would be
someone that you liked so you're not
gonna have much for that okay
why not for that just because I think
the thing that affects you most is like
what you're doing okay I like most of
this stuff that happens is on a screen
okay most of us wrong you know you're
not fifty prefer pretty good okay so at
nine fifty now now you're allowed to
work from home you can see the
accountant in him just being like right
I'm gonna have like still a fairly [ __ ]
situation for like four hundred a month
okay come on so how much it haven't you
given me for working from a hundred quid
no then recruits are eight fifty we're
down to now so if you've got any
concerns that you can think of here that
we were attempting with so we have flexi
time how about we that I like and then
we're getting on to that alright that's
the that's the [ __ ] tip of this IRC
that's where this goes to zero yeah yeah
we have no freedom of location yeah we
are working with people that you like
which didn't get much interest
yeah no done really didn't really didn't
say love you said I don't have to speak
to people that I don't we don't have to
work with quickly
well yeah though I mean on the flip side
of that it's working with people that
you do like but those people are there
now there's just also some people that I
don't like right but they're not there
anymore so that they are for me follow
our page but I didn't it they got beer
they got what I pay 50 quid come on I
paid too much they're closed e okay so
the there you're not to take the worst
twenty percent of tasks that you do that
provide you with the 80 percent of poor
leg and you can outsource that so that
reducing my hours yeah so no wonder no
II would have to move to the honors else
it's a your honors the same that your
your what you do day to day what fills
those hours is the nicer tasks
you know things right no okay how about
here's this you're no longer paid based
on your hourly wage
how will you age you're only based on
work done you have an allocation that's
more like in tunic with 650 so you know
y'all just do a morning hmm
because you can crack out there's a work
of the you can crack out the work of a
normal human in it in the morning yeah
well these so this is assuming that like
in a 35-hour workweek you can do it in
less time if you just work hard and you
definitely can you can take orally but
but then that that would suggest that
the initial allocation of work was too
low it's a generous that well I think
it's something it's not it's as in your
job you when you completed work you just
got given more but we were equalizing
for hours on the previous question
yeah that's why we said no he said no
sorry me go you have people react to
incentives so if your incentive is I
have somewhere to the black the state or
five o'clock are you going to work fast
or not or so or me I'll slow down you'll
just pace it out with you well there's
no reason to rush because you've got a
do Monday to Friday
you got a noon on Friday someone says to
you I finished my back to you quicker
scone you can go home amid daily if you
just do what happens this way but the
concern is the ending you rush so much
that your work gets done at a lower
quality isn't as long as it's at a
quality that's enough so we're never at
the moment I'm working a morning
I'm naked in fact now I'm women ever I
want a minute I'll do you 4 a.m. until 8
a.m. I don't know do you all know if the
week naked in the office before anyone
gets it you don't speak to anyone you
want from home you working from home
uh-huh we don't know you can work at
home yeah we paid for it is dumb
gumpaste are getting 600 quid for a
couple of hours working on Monday
morning naked uh-huh yeah
sounds right sounds good so my point is
and we could take this all the way up I
could say how much would it be to
exchange the job that you're doing for
something which you have full complete
creative control over how much would it
be for me to get you to be able to have
your wage grow in line with the value
that you create for the business that
you are working in keep on chugging away
I don't have money adding value like you
feel satisfaction from what you do so
you can imagine if you if you're
listening at home like think about this
in your own head think about how many
concessions you could make with all of
this sort of stuff I've managed to sit
around a dinner table
and get someone to pay me to come to his
job like hate his job a lot more than
you did a new one a massive fun hmm but
was just so keen to gout the office get
away from the people he didn't like not
after where the [ __ ] suits not after
[ __ ] blah blah blah all that sauce
bollocks
hmm he was paying me to go to his job
really but how much do you need to hate
your job to pay someone to not have to
do it anymore
it's I think the to small message me
about accountancy after the last episode
and there's something that he said in
the message which resonate with me and I
think this is probably the Kate anyone
who might doesn't like their job we need
to go in the box a box B stuff at some
point I think people think they starch
up they're like 19 fresh out there
paralti
21 or fresh out of school for a uni and
I like arts a bit crap but it'll
probably get better and then like 20
years later it's got better because of
course it isn't gonna get bad like
at 21 everything is completely novel
everything's brand-new the first time
you've done everything people aren't
really not expecting very much from you
get to go home at 5 o'clock I know your
health you've got no commitments you've
got no dependents financially yeah
usually your parents are in good health
later you're any you might be in a
relationship or you might you know be
the dark specter of immortality hasn't
started today I go at the side but I
suppose like you maybe aren't adding
much value isn't feeling that rewarding
at that point but I definitely felt I
joined and felt like this like this
wasn't really what I was expecting
waited and hoped it would get better and
didn't really but also something else
for me was I I could see because of the
way that job I did worked I could see
people who were like five six seven
years down the line and I'm looking than
going like that's that was the big one
for me looking at my seniors and saying
they are miserable life they look all to
their age and then that moment no Mona
Mona and I'm like if they'd all been
like going home at three o'clock in
their Aventador to a you know a mansion
in the in the Hills I'm like fine you
know like at least like we're all on the
same page here like it's a bit [ __ ] but
look what happens in you know because
there's a very progressive yeah yeah but
yes you can see that and I mean people
hold on to something because they always
think oh well it'll turn round it'll get
better it'll get better and then before
you know it you're 50 and it's all too
much in a typical job right you have the
ability to see your future years within
that company ahead of you and it's your
boss and your boss's boss yeah and so on
and so in some tight like some people
will think I am really jealous of my
boss and definitely like the boss of
most companies do not right but you know
most organizations are also like that
they aren't like that yeah like
everybody doesn't become the boss salary
so like by definition doesn't know this
process of elimination so that's when
the thought process for me came in of
like well alright this at some point
it's gonna be me this is the hidden in
an interview and I just want to go over
five o'clock and he loves staying till
8:00 who's gonna win the interview so
then
that said all the questions you're
asking me like what I actually think is
the best the number-one reason to leave
is if you just do something that you
like doing then you don't really think
about like I don't care about any of
that stuff really like I don't really
care about now how many hours I'm
working or I mean I'm aware of it I mean
you had to create automatic structures
on your laptop to stop you from working
yeah you have an app on your laptop
which shuts it down at five o'clock no
matter what you're doing if you're in
the middle of an email and you know an
SOS call have you been hit by a car like
there is a thing that stops your laptop
because because that's you know that's
what normal people do and I have to try
and be normal sometimes yeah like we
have conversations with girlfriends
where it's like you're a holiday you're
like please please can I just have a
couple of hours to work in the morning
oh yeah and if achill negotiation of
like right we're going away for four
days it is longer than I can get up
early on we have to do five to six hours
in the mornings and it's like what no
that's ridiculous
yes I know I'm sorry about me yeah sorry
I'm sorry for being me
but yeah so like you don't I there was a
palpable shift for me from like I'm here
I'm resenting it I want to go home I
want to be let out of this so like
actually I don't mind like if I'm
watching something like love Islands
onto the background right you know yeah
quickly so okay so someone someone might
be unhappy in their job what are some of
the real key triggers that you think
people need to be looking out for
because unfortunately this is one area
of business slash careers which I'm
wholly unqualified to talk about because
I've never except for a summer at the
AAA had a job I was like on the call arm
you were like driving the truck you did
not know about this it was you didn't
even know me at the time
but I just did calling drew my placement
yeah I was like I need some extra cash
so I went and did that for performance
didn't like it I'm guessing that's no
okay
interesting so number one behavior
pacifying behavior so self medication
when the the existential pain starts to
bear so much on your shoulders that you
like I'm gonna just blast myself on
Friday to Sunday get absolutely with all
sorts with all sickness I'm just going
to ingest things yeah yeah in desperate
hope that it's gonna make this exactly
that yeah if I ingest things so like
looking for in main types of media to
consume putting calorie very calorie
dense things in your mouth we create
putting cream in your mouth just one
form of medication after another yeah
like lots of jerk but cream that people
do like open team alcohol like get a
takeaway to Friday night because it's
Friday like you know I will have a
special breakfast on Saturday is
Saturday and like they're creating this
like perfect world over a weekend
because then GB is so unpleasant and
this is different to work hard play hard
I don't think it's the same I think work
I play hard is like have to find time
boxes for when you do productive deep
work and home times are you relaxing
fully it's not the same as spending
Friday to Sunday semi-conscious and then
rolling into Monday work hard drink are
here we go again
it's uh suppose it's like living the
living for the weekend thing isn't it
like if you really like you know when
people like post everything on Instagram
being like hump day and we'll share
about like our it's Wednesday or halfway
through that [ __ ] cuz it's at one closer
to Friday when I can go out and get
drunk and forget about Monday to Friday
I don't need to judge people that do
this by the way like this is definitely
experience that we've been through
ourselves and done this and I just think
really it's a red flag it's just a
warning sign this
Damien it's alright what's he been doing
with unique yeah there's no yeah you
took you what you are totally right like
people should be allowed to enjoy
themselves on a weekend but if that
enjoyment is medication or if that
enjoyment on a weekend is done to excess
well if it's done in an effort to be
like an anesthetic for what's going on
in a week yeah so like there's one thing
like going out on a Friday with you
mates because you love going out on
Friday with you mates and actually like
you really like you like thought
otherwise versus I really need a drink
because it's Friday because my bosses
are cutting oh yeah because I have to
wear a suit every day yeah or I have to
get up and go to work at this time I'll
do work which isn't creative or all of
the things that you gave me six hundred
or five hundred fifty pounds back yeah
yeah well no one money but yeah so
anything to try in like avoid the Monday
to Friday reality mmm so that's thus
that's a warning sign what else I think
just not like it's hard because I think
it's really easy when we both had like
as something to go and do so I think
sighted you're part of the reason why I
was so like auntie it was I neat I was
very aware of an alternative of like how
interested I was in that and like the
possibility where it might go that's
interesting though because if that
wasn't there would be one of two things
would happen either you would feel like
you'd lost your mojo and be like turning
up for working alone this is meant to be
my ultimate purpose in life and I really
don't feel like it
manages with my with with some vague
sense of my inner purpose or you invest
all of that desire for purpose into
something like vicarious enjoyment or
something else so like going like and
again I was gonna say like I don't care
like investing it all into a dog or a
football team or something that like it
becomes the surrogate for all of your
meaning in your life and that will
naturalize passion yeah I think some
because I often one more child if probe
didn't exist would I have just like
lentil love accounting but maybe I would
I think that I'm convinced that that's
what some people do I think you could if
Previn didn't exist and you were on the
truck that you were in I think you would
have gone into it an adjacent field that
still allowed you to leverage your
express other things yeah because I
think the in the Soviet of workers like
it a social media marketing yeah
from probably now yes not up or
something is still just doing
spreadsheets that Dan Gibson has a
really you sees the world is like
everyone just doing spreadsheet like it
doesn't matter what they're doing is
true it's all just spreadsheets like
every Graduate scheme II we were enough
in this business must be legit
you run plug promo let me tell you done
my business it's good not great
I've seen your spreadsheet yes it's just
that you don't do much of them yeah no
that's true and one thing that I can
think again another warning flag
potentially for someone who's thinking
about their career is how hard is it to
get yourself out of bed in the morning
when you've got work yeah like if you
really really have to [ __ ] force
yourself out of bed and you two coffees
feet by the time you get into the office
and you just doesn't like a fire mm-hmm
we did an episode for what the name of
this podcast was before it was called
modern wisdom that has never been aired
on purpose and meaning it took two hours
but one thing that came out of that that
I don't forget is the best synopsis of
what his purpose in life is a reason to
gala bed in the morning take the route
matter at the coolest way just the
roughest human way to work out what
purposes are getting outta bed in the
morning for something I remember back
here saying um after I quit and was
doing this she like I was just whistling
one morning like I was like drinking my
coffee like getting ready put my own
clothes on whistling and she was like
she like stopped and looked at me and
like me being like you taking the piss
cuz like building up with that by every
morning was like in fact I think is
really nice
I don't wanna go to work he was singing
a song I don't want to go into work I
think that that's a good indication but
yeah so you're so lovely okay because
the fact that the question was even like
are you taking the piss it was so
unusual at us so yes I shall take away
your night stops becoming work but oh
I'm moving on too quickly
do not think that do not think the
reason that you got asked about that is
that whistling is so naturally heigh-ho
[Laughter]
cost me in the morning yeah so escape
this behavior not one get up in the
morning mojo lost the carries enjoyment
of putting your meaning into something
and the stuff I said before is well like
you just don't like it but you don't
feel excited you don't feel because
there will be people who work in the
night if our job I assume you love it
who feel like their value to feel like
they had a lot you feel like they're
really good in it so this is my megawatt
of Independence this my next question
which is you can be unhappy in your job
and many people are think the statistic
is that 85% of people in the US are
either neutral neutral or actively
dissatisfied as actively unengaged
as opposed to actively engage 15% people
in the US that's it so the only the
option for you is not only to go away
for yourself though absolutely you can
move to another bureaucratic
organization you can move to a startup
you can move to other things so the next
question is
oK we've worked out that someone if
you're not unhappy in your job then like
fantastic listen and enjoy the remainder
of these episodes use them to supplement
your understanding of the business world
but you don't need to think about how
they go to apply to what you're doing
and stick at what you do and become
better and move up within that
organization whereas next little root
down the thought tree is I'm unhappy
should I work for myself
or should I move to another company and
work for someone else how do we how do
we work that up on that note there's a
very so you this this thought experiment
you did where you take away certain
things you know dude you move food the
the guy that is like now very famous and
and rich acrobat he initially set out
set up his life in the way that you
described to start with which was that
he had a job that was like 10 till 4 and
he was aims like bookkeeping or like
admin stuff that was quite cognitively
easy it allowed him to our lunch break
flexible time and he set it up so that
he was able to do as much like dancing
around him the grass as possible in
training and just enjoying his life and
didn't care about like up was a called
upward mobility mobility or anything
like that it was just like happy to just
turn up do the job and and set up his
life so that his job as low stress and
low comments his load incidentally he
ended up becoming very very well yeah so
not the people that I come into contact
with you love that job usually aren't
doing it because of the salary and I
think a lot of the people that I've
spoken to you were like people who are
like in one of our programs who are
leaving their job it's they they started
it because of like the gross annual
salary so I think certainly the world I
was in mind there's a lot of talk about
no people are leaving that I can't see
firm to go into industry all people talk
about is that annual gross number
because how many days just but she's not
say to no wasn't getting chipped until I
got lager for home but like no one ever
talks about the
net pay which really is all because you
don't get I was back but money renews
monthly so every month someone puts
money in your bank and says I'd like all
these hours please but no one thinks
about that they think like that it's 55
grand instead of 50 yeah so the what was
the point of a pocket man did you if
you're working in a job that allowed oh
yeah so like you said you're in this
position you don't like your job what do
you do I would say do you have anything
in your job now that you are much better
than your peers up so I think a lot of
people have like a skill that they might
be like how it's standing out for
example that's a specific skill and you
think well could I go and just do that
somewhere else for example it may be not
chase the number but it's set just chase
the interest and this is I mentioned
this in the last podcast about what Alan
Watts
speaks about like if you are genuinely
really good at something firstly you'll
enjoy doing it because you'll feel
competent you'll feel like you're adding
value and if you're very good at it
chances are you'll be able to command a
good salary or a good fear you whatever
so that me then manifests in the
business or you may need that skill may
be required in another business so like
people who are like interested in
photography for example who might be
exceptionally good at that might go and
do that front of the business or go do
it themselves or whatever but I think
the decisions are like set up your own
business Hoss there has to be a desire
to want to do that I think that if that
if there's not a natural like I really
want to do that for and I think it's
probably a bad idea and did not probably
as well if your particular passion or
whatever is that you have this pull
towards doing for a profession hmm can't
be facilitated by somebody else yeah so
yeah with me I couldn't go work for it
couldn't go work for another promo
company running these events in these
clubs because they didn't exist yeah and
we were the same yeah yeah so I I think
that probably comes from pursuing an
interest rather than a salary and if it
turns out financially successful that's
kind of a side benefit yeah on a
point about the salary thing my flatmate
University went out of uni and went
straight into they did it this was 13
years ago about 12 years ago so did have
been before placement years were quite
as ubiquitous as they are now that
pretty much everyone that I know either
does a gap year with all the traveling
or does a placement year in industry or
whatever it might be especially in
business relate degrees um he 21 years
old out of university
wet-behind-the-ears had lived at
boarding school throughout all of like
13 to 18 as well so just being
completely insulated for all this time
well-rounded guy went astray of
university straight into the LD graduate
scheme oh yeah she's 60 grand ago with a
free Audi yeah but no one told him 70
hours a week and he'd be traveling all
over the Northeast yeah I remember I
knew a few people who it wasn't Aldi and
maybe Tesco that is similar but the Aldi
was the one that everyone spoke about
was being like cuz the salary was the
mental side see how I remember that as
well they're thinking about all DS but
people who are sent to like Bradford for
six months no warning and you might
borrow each new day you know what the
like on ramping process was for that you
have to spend the first two days as a
checkout assistant you have to work your
way from there yeah but you just like an
unbelievably accelerated yeah it's like
it's like you move through someone's
career of 15 years in a space of like
two months that's quite clever actually
back experience we've said it on
business principles 101 you need to
understand everything from the ground
floor of a submission to the manager
that makes sense but I mean so this guy
was in OTC so he's an officer training
corps there's a hard guy like [ __ ]
could stick stuff out was the Xavier
grant and he was you know 21 years old
with 60 grand a year come in an Audi a4
parked outside
mhm lasted six months yeah lasted for as
long as his probation was through so
they didn't look like he quit the first
hurdle so when you when that sort of
thing isn't right for you it's
interesting one question that it comes
to mind at the moment
do you think that there is a job out
there for everybody to like a job that
someone loves out there for everybody
probably not a degree
I think that there's this like you know
you you can get paid for your passion
and everybody can can just monetize what
they love mine and it's like I still
[ __ ] need my Street cleaned I still
[ __ ] need that's a different question
thus is there a person for every job
versus is there a job for every person
and I think the the problem is that
everyone wants to be an Instagram
influencers Juice Plus coach but maybe
not but there's vast demand for certain
jobs and there's very little so like we
know someone who very cleverly so he's a
smart guy had an option to go into
Investment Banking or corporate jobs and
instead said I'm gonna go into
construction because I have this level
of interest and drive and something that
I know that if I were to apply it to
Investment Banking I would be in a in a
sea of extreme competition and not get
anywhere whereas if I enter more of a
blue ocean and really pound it in the
construction management sector so he saw
a weak weak competition professionally
yeah it's a particular sector so it's
like if you're willing to do a job that
is kind of boring or unsexy like so
under someone else who runs a portaloo
business and he's doing really well
hmm the kids like it's not a sexy these
maybe but it doesn't care but I still
kind of hunting for the for the Paycheck
though isn't it like that I suppose it
is all just about so it's kind of the
it's the Marc Munson so I'm not giving a
[ __ ] it's like it's what you're willing
to tolerate soon as a part of my book we
talks a lot like the the person who
loves the nine-to-five job is the person
who is alright with the [ __ ] things
about the 95 job the person who's good
as an entrepreneur as a person alright
with the fact that like next month you
might make no money he might make that
money now you know next six months you
might be out of business I like that
because there's no value judgments
applied to either one it's like what is
your tolerance for uncertainty or for
yeah you know security so that's that
that's the next literally the next
question like
what we're talking about should I work
for myself choosing the role the
relative benefit versus risk or
downsides just last night no I said to
Youssef that I had a special question
for it right no I'll do it now so I
wanted to ask you Civ about specific
Arabic approaches to business because
Yousef is mining Johnny's window into
the Arab world and I just wondered if
you have any family members or any any
friends that are Arab who sell batteries
have a particular approach to business
and if you had anything
I mean signature to do with the Stars do
with our business stuff I mean my my
Arab family still believe that
homosexuality is a is it is a disease
that is spread through advertising on
the lot so like this is the 1660s but
IRA so you're gonna have to elucidate on
Arab business principles Arab approaches
to doesn't I'm sure there was a module a
uni where you could study like because I
don't think I'm different
oh yes no no I don't mean it I mean I
own cultural cultural approaches do not
Islamic finance principles because that
is that is very that's a thing in itself
all right I wrote a dissertation on that
oh yeah I mean not the thing that I know
loads about no yes I mean the thing that
he doesn't know anything about that you
would like him to yes like if you if
you've made if you made your brother run
a business okay
or your sister yeah that's right
so there's so much my brother has done
business in Egypt and they're very much
about like oh come in Habibi we will do
big deal with you again like making big
promises and I'm not actually delivering
on or is that just part and parcel
lay and kind of this is this is Egypt
but also there is more of a sense of
like maybe it's a political climate but
there's there's a situation where like
entrepreneurial characters will create
jobs for themselves
our over-exploitation so like you'll
have people who are employed by Mol's to
open automatic doors for people
so the awesome was that just because
they have to fill out their numbers like
so that the mall has to like set a
certain number of employees for them so
there's a man who waves at the sensor
yes are they linked in what's a tip yeah
but then there are other people who will
just create their own so that the in the
street they might like you'll be parking
and they'll like stand behind you like
yeah yeah
I don't need your help I'm fine and then
basically they're blackmailing you
because if you leave and you don't tip
them they know yeah well it's a
dysfunctional all us so it's the same
and I am around these guys all the time
and they're lovely
I just wish that they would go and work
behind the bar toilet attendants in
nightclubs ok similar approach I just
I'd like you to be cocky I want to get
my own paper towel I want to put the
soap on my own hands that I don't want
to feel guilty every time that I go to
the bathroom when I work in clubs that
if I wasn't doing what they do I would
invest like the first weeks wages or how
about how long it takes and I would buy
an Apple contactless pointed pen because
like and I say how much do you want it
I'm so sure that all of these guys are
running legit it doesn't it doesn't
matter about that I don't be saying but
like how many people have a couple of
quid how many people have a contacts
card or an iPhone or so this is I just
think they can get more even if it even
if it's now taxed
god forbid no you know I'm not this is
like a silly me I've heard someone
describe
and homeless people as trading in guilt
or trials in a blog post and trading in
shame it was it was an old coach that I
had that said that I was like it took me
a while to kind of get around what he
was saying but I suppose like homeless
people I don't think they are trading in
shame I think they have no choice but
the people in the yeah that you write
the social cost of leaving is like war
he did get the paper towel for me even
hadn't wanted to it's imposing a service
on you or like in America if you Benson
New York yeah we get people go like rap
music you get buy my CD and so it's like
so it's a homeless people in America do
this a lot I've just come back from
America and when when someone has no
other option is one I'm like come on
like get your salon like I'm sweet as
long as it's not stealing things it's
not illegal like if you can make some
cash then fantastic but when we were in
a soft-top car and guys would come up
with like that dirty rag t-shirt and be
like hey man you want your car washed
I'm like man I'm [ __ ] red light how
are you gonna be able to get the car in
the next we found seconds yeah with that
don't [ __ ] it and I've just seen you
take off is that important business
principle behind that isn't that which
is don't force something on the market
when there's no demand for it
Devilfish [ __ ] service in the market
doesn't yeah lucky you it's not for you
to decide what the market should should
have and should want it's like you look
for the demand and you redirect it to
your service because you offer a better
option than there was a vendor that's in
Vegas it was just standing there going
does anybody have any money for hookers
and cocaine and I like I've never felt
more of a pulling but to just go like
because he made me he made me laugh and
I thought like so he's redirected the
amount of like the holes on that guy to
just but this is what I'm gonna do with
the money can I have some money and he
looked like from his little collection
that like he was you know he heard
George Carlin address that where he's
like when people say like oh maybe you
see a homeless guy and now I'm not
giving any money he's just gonna spend
it on cigarettes and alcohol
gonna spend on and what else do you
think is gonna spend it on like he's not
gonna go buy some real estate is he so
that was a point that rory sutherland
made about the fact that if you give
money to people in small amounts they
will buy immediately gratifying things
because in small increments money can
only give you small amounts of happiness
and conversely people think don't give
people from low income like all of their
years allowance of tip like payments in
one go because they're just gonna spunk
it all and do whatever but the converse
is actually shown to be true if you give
someone a hundred pounds every week that
they'll just keep on buying in fact if
you give someone five thousand two
hundred pounds they'll actually think oh
my god I've got five thousand two
hundred pounds look at all of the things
I can do with this five thousand two
hundred pounds that's actually save so
much yeah I can invest so I can buy oh I
should buy a bike and then I can get
don't worry and then I'm gonna have
advice yeah as opposed to what can you
do with a hundred quid a week let get
yourself pissed and have it have a tap
and there's a wine gums why do companies
W do and fudge so Arabic approaches to
business we've got the fact that they're
a bit like forthcoming and everyone kind
of plays the big man anything else any
of those sort of signature playing the
big man over-promising under-delivering
mhm
it's very macho kind of not wanted to
lose face and being very kind of like a
quite chess BTW as everyone does
everyone wear shirts that are opened
down to the stone I'm massively
generalizing that's not the point if
that's what we're trying to do I imagine
very hard negotiations shouting very
passionate but but then again my Dax wax
but likey Brylcreem then again like that
you know all our countries are countries
that operate functionally and have the
full spectrum so there are there are
very you know sensible quiet business
people that work for kind of mmm
corporate what we want to hear about
just wants you to pretend like Ruben
drug dealers
like that's what we thought thank you
right right getting back to whether or
not we should work for ourselves so
relative benefit versus risk we just
touched on it there I think personal
preference and actual approach to risk
is a big part of this that can you deal
with potentially going for two months or
three months without earning any money
yeah that's both a financial question
and a psychological question mmm are you
able to take the concern of [ __ ]
I might make no money this month mmm and
then I might not make any money next
month despite having done the audios all
right with it yeah that's why I could
never be a trader can't be every time I
translate every time that I try and
trade can't do its it so this is a like
yeah a case of what's your threshold
because trade even full-time traders say
don't trade for income trade for wealth
creation wealth like growth of capital
but had a separate income because if
you're relying on your monthly paycheck
is dependent on your profits from
training day to day and you're watching
that but a horribly stressful event on
the stick ah it's the same reason why
surgeons aren't allowed operator family
members so is that true I imagine so
yeah ladies can't see can't say they
would for treating you you just
panicking so they buy or sell or do
something stupid if I was a full-time
trader my a long night Mike the dog
penis would be a boy constantly
blackberry pulsating Ubisoft the boys
the boys are laughing a couple of forays
I have made into trading have been
things you like row trading I did do
really well I like I like I like the
trailer for the new Call of Duty game so
I bought some Activision is that's a
really smart play and I bet it worked
out really well run up there you go like
all these people looking at like GDP
forecasts and you just like well call GT
comes out in a month or so
well these traders gonna miss that
can I talk to ya what else what are some
of the other things that people need to
consider so we're talking about a
sideways move from your current job
which you hate mmm
into potentially another job or then
perhaps working for yourself so because
even if sorry to interject even if you
have a passion that you like and you can
monetize and do all the rest of it
if psychologically your profile doesn't
allow you to not to have self-directed
work and not have a boss who's laying
out your structure for you mm-hmm it's
gonna be difficult maybe you could get a
PA who could try and structure your week
perhaps or something like that that guy
who paid a PA paid someone to slap him
every time he went off task we heard
about this know the old limit Pomodoro
dis ya know I thought what have you sent
this article to is it a guy paid someone
to just sit in a cafe and watch him work
and slap him whenever he like change tab
or changed up or anything and he said it
didn't get slapped I was every penny
yeah he said I was the most productive
so he only paid a paper swap was he paid
per hour per hour that's like playing
for clicks or impressions yes however
think much less what you said there
about the sideways moves really
interesting interesting point since the
first decision is should I work for
myself or should I not can I tolerate
the uncertainty of income and then
secondly like there is probably a lot of
benefit a lot of advantage to working
for like a small startup of like 5
people or 10 people just doing that yeah
so judge or Justine are you exposing
yourself to a huge potential upside with
like maybe even if you can get like a
share in the company what George did but
also the sideways move like if you're
gonna serve like we were saying with
Johnny like going from accounting to
something that you can still leverage
those skills but in a different at least
go into the right sector like go into
something that you yeah slightly more
aligned with what you wanna do is there
a moment when you were like right this
is it I'm out of here
apart from obviously if that that moment
was technically when you sent the when
you send the message that said I'm
leaving it so you don't send a message
you go into an a dessert menu go to our
click or
further form in the press yes oh you
know when you feel like they're gonna no
no please don't go please don't go
what's the row for this decision as
permanent consequences it felt very
final whether a cancellation funnel no
there wasn't actually there's nothing no
objection handling was it was it too
expensive with it are you sure
and then the are you should have button
within the opposite color here I mean I
think it is it's green green green green
ocean filling out the form backwards in
the shower and I was like yeah yeah I
press like remembers I was actually good
I'm definitely she was like yeah well
thanks Becca oh this is the monthly
immediate moment like what am I done and
you're like ah she this is excited side
whistling but it was immediately me I
tried before I left I tried to do
something within the firm that was like
a bit more in line with what I found
interesting so it was like they were
looking at bringing in yellow didn't you
like AI and smart technology and stuff
and they were looking for a team of
people that like front that and I got
offered the role to do it to be on that
team I have a goat out in London and
Mike you get to see the Canary Wharf
office and it is like super like yo
[ __ ] out this is a mystical God got
offered that and then told my client
manager there's so many did which was
like oh yeah cool but like you're doing
on top of your or would it work fine
because it literally thought at that
moment like I've done well I didn't say
it to it but an energy I then spoke to
on the phone and I said like would they
be able to enforce that like if you just
don't know like they want me I can you
know it's all under the same there is a
call that they do where they say like
what are you going to do like we can
talk about matching salary and myself
like you know who where you go to work
it's like I'm actually I'm going to go
home to sit Muppets to start and try and
grow and online fitness business and she
was just like all right well I can't I
can't compete with what was yours you
sir very very similar it was like
suddenly I'm the boss in its era it was
throughout the year having to keep it
completely under wraps that I'm applying
to med school because it obviously would
be the end of the job because you're on
like a training program where they're
investing more in you even flatmates
that no family didn't really know I
think Johnny knew towards the end [ __ ]
me
so you've got them like full it's all
Secret Service cops body will the
college's death mode and like preparing
for this entrance exam which was like
every day after work for hours weekend's
just all waiting times pounding it
through the whole the whole time and
then run a pasta I was like right I've
got like three weeks to give in my
notice and then to get set up so sent
the bus an email soon as I've got the
result can i chat with you on Monday
medic on Monday it's that time really
she was like so you're quitting yeah
like joking and I was like okay what do
you what you're good to do I was like um
I'm gonna go study medicine which was
that oh thank god I thought you were to
see what what for Goldman okay good luck
but you must specialize don't be GP your
GP yeah was there a moment when you knew
that you wanted to not do Blackrock and
to go and do quite early on in Black
Rock okay because probably trying to
find that the moai identify yeah yeah so
first of all it's like the you guys in
New York you see the intense passion
everyone has for the job like it's only
for a month in New York and you have to
do like a bunch of induction stuff
see people there who are just all like
Harvard Yale Princeton super like
masters in various financial Sciences
and really just so passionate about the
stuff [ __ ] love it
they absolutely get such a stiffy over
and I people like they'll have high
high-powered exacts from different parts
of the company coming in and that
they're like bursting for these
questions what do you think about like
potassium exports in Kazakhstan you
trying to the mutia over breakfast you
know ours is a nice breakfast than the
night yeah so I what do you think about
fixed income in Europe I'm really
interested in bond pricing and so you
can't maintain this and then once you
get back you look at the the progression
the people who are ten years ahead of
you anything I don't want like this is
the the direction that you sell and you
don't want to be that personally don't
want like nothing about this whole path
is they draw me you didn't want to be
that person right then
yeah so ten years of that person as if
it gets better but it doesn't
yeah because I think like I remember
thinking like what is the best case
scenario I stay here and everything goes
perfectly what will be happening and
like I'll be round that corner much
other than I am now having been here for
ages I'll still be looking up a very
similar laptop but just looking at
slightly different spreadsheets got one
screen as well on screen yeah or they
have sometimes they give them a like VGA
to VGA or HDMI now but like a lot more
responsibility a lot more money but like
same building longer hours more like
your life exactly the same just went in
the time that you have when you get home
before you go to bed like if you want
can buy like really posh things online
and then of like seltzer water like
cells like the loads of it and then like
you got a nice holidays so in then it
and like the 25 days a week that they
give you
yeah sorry yeah yeah 25 days a year it
that you can spend out of the work
you can go somewhere that cost you more
money so as Americans my like holiday
time like standing in surgery like
shadowing surgery goes like a
pre-application thing but how did you
have a nice holiday like yeah what loads
of kid thanks to me yeah but I think if
the best-case scenario isn't like that
might what's the point yeah definitely
might as well so I thought like I'm just
going to position myself in something
where I'm like if that really works out
are we gonna class
that's the Gemini all the pressures in
there like what what decision would
producing us look I'm just going yes
such a great metric well I'm like you in
a job you have someone decides you're
upside for you and you're upside is on a
trajectory trajectory you can't really
accelerate that you can't do a year
faster yeah how much does this
trajectory but it's three years to
qualifying and then it's like normally
two years and you make manager then it's
a certain amount of time manager than me
obviously yeah most people leave that's
the reason why so it's so weird isn't it
like that you progression because
there's so many people creaming off the
top and because progression is based in
a lot of bureaucratic organizations
based on seniority non capability it's
based on time serves a lot of the time
because otherwise like you would employ
grads and then the smartest grad you
would just take him up here and give him
the big it like if he's legitimately
smarter than all the management and like
why would you not promote him but he's
got a half of the experience but well
yeah but there are points at which like
a experiences outpaced by intelligence
but the this idea that like you can't
really accelerate that
so the gonna be in there for that amount
of time anyway you don't really like
that I don't know I think it's a lot to
do with the way the people are wired in
yeah hope that people aren't getting
like triggered by well like you can be
but this is just our experience this is
the way that I'm it's a way that and
it's the fact that all three of us a
wide the same way but I think a lot more
people are them than think that they are
I certainly like a lot of my friends at
working in accountancy jobs in you know
seem to at least I don't say to me like
I hate it but I
suppressing my feelings like they seem
to like it and I we disagree on it but
you know muscle preference that's a
preference area like I think it's
interesting that I feel like I get a lot
of judgement about what I'm doing I
judge them I suppose but like as long as
they enjoy it I think it's great so I
think maybe going back to the Daniel /
jigsaw analogy like different people
value different things right
hmm like those people it was totally
like you said about jus GMO food that he
had a job which facilitated him to do
the things he cared about which happened
to be his side-project
of training and doing acrobatics and
other things like that well the people
might really [ __ ] love their family
the family might be a huge yeah of the
thing as long as they've got the money
that they need to be able to take life
on and then spend time because I got
massive family are the reveal of the
brothers and sisters or mom and dad or
their boyfriend a girlfriend a future
wife or whatever sick like that's that's
fantastic we are three slightly autistic
young men with with no family and so
what our preferences yeah our doesn't
what I do too
weirdly enough we filled the void I say
this all the time like Darren my
business partner has a family he has two
dogs and a wife and now two beautiful
big boys I also have a family minor just
businesses and projects on the site
podcast and I do my modeling and I do
traveling and I do you know attitude
into role Adela do property and blah
blah like that's that is my surrogate
family because I think that a lot of
people have this pent up forward
momentum that they need to invest into
something and they might invest into dog
football team some sort of passion they
might invest into family like growth of
the home unit whatever it might be or
they might invest it into business and
it's weird that there is you right
there's this weird sort of value
judgement about well you do gyarah the
hustle and grind say that you've you
know if you're not making a business
then it's [ __ ] [ __ ] may and
you're just working for the man it's
like well no like if you value the stuff
outside of working for the man crack on
the man's gonna facilitate because you
can turn up to work you have to do
something catastrophically [ __ ] [ __ ]
to not get a paycheck at the end of the
month you have to literally are fired
yeah which is actually a legal process
which is a nightmare
like to fire someone is difficult lemon
the oh yeah I think that
so there's definitely judgments both
sides like I think entrepreneurs judge
people in jobs because looking like 10
word your father the fun way and like
people a job judge judge or prayers
cause either way smile I never do
anything yeah but I think the the only
time I think it's a shame on both sides
is when people are doing something and
they're just like hugging that short
term everything because they are so in
Trump and transpire this idea that like
when I earn X I will it'll I it'll all
be brilliant and like something that
happens when you are running your own
business is you're exposed to like when
you when you're earning salary like you
get like - run - run - run - run might
yeah you get a bit of savings and maybe
get a bonus but when you're entrepreneur
like you might even know Grund know you
might be this and it might be this so
like this month then you you don't think
you know this maybe then this is the
biggest revenue month we've ever had and
program graduations well yeah but like I
don't care and I thought I would like I
remember the entire time doing this
thinking like when we pass X I'll be so
but like I'm I live in a reality where
you're it's proven that it just doesn't
affect anything like there's a number on
a spreadsheet so why that's different
and it's passed a mark that you set for
yourself arbitrarily when you think of
your life like that anything like what
would be different like at a wake up not
have a coffee and I already buy the
coffee yeah would I buy a nicer coffee
well I mean like I don't have a coffee
at all but
but like time what nothing psychic but
then are you like I fell on a pair of
shoes that without buy a nice pair of
shoes okay if I did because I my son
I'll change you like yeah you probably
could afford all the other little
upgrades that you want now like it
mister money mustache oh yeah where he
says just get the upgrades immediately
it's more like he's like has like a
really nice coffee and read a nice piece
of chocolate and it costs him like a
quid more yeah right this quality of
life is like what than if you if you if
your income was to double what do you
think what else would you do so this is
something that I think about a lot and
it's something I've talked about a lot
what a shame that I've not done missing
to start the podcast but the relative
difference between a materialistic you
are and your means to be able to get
that end mm-hm is one of the biggest
determinants I think in terms of
someone's satisfaction especially now
yeah like if if you're very
materialistic but you don't have the
means it's big sadness Astra fee like if
you if you've because I don't know I
don't know that you could class it as
like a genetic a predisposition but it's
certainly something that your family
will have instilled in you if your
family always bought nice things if
there was a atmosphere of keeping up
with the Joneses if prudence was kind of
looked down on or just wasn't something
that was drilled in then you are going
to have a higher natural level of
spending and we do like all of us here
are quite scriptures and savers and if
that's you you need to get your [ __ ]
nose to the grindstone because you're
going to be unhappy because if there is
high preference for dispense stuff if
you like nice things if you always have
to have Gucci sliders and you always
have to have that sauce so if you better
hope that you're gonna get a [ __ ]
good job well the fact is I walked in in
this t-shirt and both were like that's
not your t-shirt I spend a lot less on
stuff I thought I'd spend money on so I
thought I'd spend money on like
constantly here getting new clothes and
like constantly like I thought I'd have
like a laptop the latest laptops and
also stuff but actually the stuff I
spend like disproportionate amounts of
money on it's like [ __ ] training
course of course yeah
yeah I do have moments right well why am
i doing this and it's not because I can
earn more money so I can buy more
supplies yeah I just like find it really
interesting when you just when you just
like in a world where it's just all just
really interesting well you always make
a return on investing in yourself in
some way so especially business coaching
or business like any anything unless you
buy the four thousand pounds down to 350
pounds what was that on the ultimate
bundle yeah do you support a support
bundle yeah just got fully up souls went
on a website saying 5000a was like down
- down - down to this one ninety ninety
nine point eight percent off for some
reason
so yeah the aterial ismond means to
achieve that or to get to that is like a
real big thing and I'm very thankful
that I don't have that I've had the same
car now for four and a half years and
things likes of know you have Rena Rena
low lying my gun there was an RS and
then after that I had the Audi soft top
and now I've got lace at the point where
I've forgotten you have him it's been
it's been that time but in that same
time I've got four houses yeah like
because for me and even that's not about
wealth creation it's about I am
liberating myself from industry which is
very fickle and I just feel like levar
bailed yeah unless less at the mercy of
something that's like that but yeah it
do well what we all do in companies that
like hockey stick and what mental growth
wise would not be or buy Lamborghinis
we'd probably all be like right like who
can we bring into the team like what
let's get this office does it be cool
although I go online with you maybe like
maybe tip will share one but like but
you know if I can't you can get one if
you have 50 million pounds in mm but now
it doesn't trust me that like what is
the amount without which that seems
reason I've got percentage of your
if you tell you what yeah that's a very
good one for another time then mmm
let's do it is the next thought
experiment and business wonder through
how much money does use of the hunting
spend on any of it frivolously oh yeah
so all of us have been in situations so
your is your trading story it's on on is
home time if you fail it's like you were
you were put in a position that again so
that the reason I reference the revenue
thing is I just don't think unless you'd
like have this big windfall like
inheritance or something
people aren't presented with like the X
amount of money in there ten times up
something certainly it doesn't really
happen in life
but if we've all been in a situation
with something like that's happened in
has it affected you happiness like happy
have you suddenly thought like oh I'm so
much up your life's complete now what is
it to do anything else is that really
well sight study in America isn't it I
think it's certainly five thousand
dollars in America or fifty it's nothing
that wasn't fifty eight thousand pounds
per year is the point at which an
increase in salary essentially has no
impact on your amount of happiness and
mental heisman yeah fifty about you
think bollocks
[ __ ] off yeah that's quite scary then 51
pitching thought everyone's like driving
towards must actually people who were
already over that he was still going
over more even though data suggests I'm
their past experience like which is even
more available to those people but yeah
crazy you're suppose if you if you're in
a job you're thinking about leaving it
and you've experienced a pay rise and
your happiness hasn't increased in
proportion to pay rise leave there we go
any other any other point I sort
professionally not take my advice yeah
so you know like a Daniel sloth has the
number of divorces and breakups that
jigsaw has caused in his Twitter bio God
like if we start totting up the number
of people that have left their jobs
together do not ring me I repeat do not
ring me and tell me that you've left
your job because of this another a
strong and frank discussion with all of
your friends and then message me at
Chris relax or just enroll appropriate
business on teach you how do we've had a
lot of people that quit their jobs yes
because that revenue just could be it's
so ballsy but this is so the other thing
as well to consider which is a toll but
the element to this is most jobs in the
same attitude you move who had his most
normal jobs that don't take up too much
of your time will not prohibit you from
starting a business on it yes like why
can you not because the inevitably the
first two years no matter how [ __ ]
good your business is the first year of
it especially if you've never done
business before the first two to three
years of it you're gonna see growth pace
which is so slow it's [ __ ] on Rocky's
losses but most of the time I statistics
you'll see big losses in the first year
definitely local business um what's
making up two million quid revenue
bonkers bonkers like not like big
businesses might back to remember that
the book is a book this really
well-known book called ready fire aim
which talks about like challenge from
zero to million acquiring a base of
customers to generate a million in
revenue but you'll be lost make with the
challenge from a million to 10 million
just trying to become profitable [ __ ] me
like I can't get around it but yeah like
you're right like econ there are things
you can wake up and do in your Tower to
how long you want to work but that's not
gonna make the business grow any faster
chances are and that's you're doing like
really revenue generating them that's
one of the things people are saying
about the podcast ah hey man like so I
you know what you're gonna do you're
gonna you're gonna like to start doing
start doing that more like ads on yeah
yeah cool like what's more like produce
more than 2 episodes a week there's
nothing limit on how much time people
can listen and I think that's about
twice a week if I'm wrong tell me but
I'd love to go I'm not wrong so like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
yeah upgrade the [ __ ] production
quality but that's just a matter of
investing in kit hmm what would I like
if I was doing the [ __ ] podcast
full-time what would I do you do you
differently just write up loads of
really really [ __ ] well prepped notes
that's why the top podcasts are not
purely profit based like they are that
they started probably still are very
much passion projects you April and
you know like the Joe Rogan one kind of
has become profitable as a result but
I'm sure he's turned away a lot of
sponsors and things in truth someone's
tried to pull him onto a exclusive
podcast network so you know like I Heart
Radio or something like you have to you
have to download the app to listen to
Joe Rogan like in it that would be worth
to any company it would be worth a
stupid amount it'd be great for him
personally but he's but he's beyond
probably beyond the fifty eight thousand
pounds it'll be great personally but
terrible for his legacy yeah you don't
said it easy to the point where like
brand is more important than revenue
really in terms like short term I think
it's always been that way
but has it even even if you were viewing
it purely financially it was likely do
we made this decision short term where
he can monetize harder even if it was
financially kill the would have to be it
would be an inordinate amount money yeah
like Arab sheikh money like billions on
a side point have you seen the video
where someone's cut all of the times
that Donald Trump has said the word
billions I have yeah billions and
billions and billions it's about ten
minutes long yeah I remember hearing Jim
Wendler who made 531 like the least
strength program on the Internet here he
did like a thirty minute video about
like business and he's a super like like
no [ __ ] million potatoes like big
old bearded power lifter done lots of
drugs very honest about it
extremely strong squat a thousand pounds
like you know that was enough solid
thousands all of us you don't get to
that point by like getting sucked in by
farts like that man has squatted then
did he Scott in two thousand pounds and
he just said when you're starting just
don't do it for income don't do it to be
your income source because you just make
decisions that prioritize getting money
in now over the long-term trajectory
which is why we we talk about like have
your freedom number the number that you
the aromatase to get to you feel like
right I could leave if I wanted to so
know what that is for you know what your
costs are build your business to that
point and then either
you've doubled your income or great you
can leave and maintain your also great
like zero downside infinite upside it's
a really nice little rule well I hope
that we've mastered one I hope that
we've helped some people in
understanding where they're at with
their career and stuff like that at the
moment I think we had some questions in
me we have had some questions submit I
promise that we will get round to them
you might have to peel off a little bit
of business principles one or three so
that we can do them any stuff that you
want us to speak about whatever the
topics are whatever the issues are that
you're encountering with career or
business feel free to leave it in the
comments below
and do not forget to get a lovely
buttery sauce from so write they will
send out one of their great manipulation
tools to one person who leaves us review
on iTunes or wherever else you are
listening so leave us a review there and
I'll choose someone and let you know
okay thanks bye
[Music]
you